that's like the woman's point of view  you know what I mean like but they  didn't want to get if they wanted to get  to know me from me  it'd been a little different no but I  was saying like from the men's point of  view it's gonna be and this is just you  know again what what the guys are saying  yeah but it's like yeah you made all  those like you let all those guys hit  for free and now I gotta do all this  well it's not even I don't even look at  it as well you did it for free because  I'm not a prostitute like and I'm not a  glorified escort right and that's that  might not be how you look at it but this  is that's crazy this is this is just  like this is how men see it